[Musik]
mai zusammen und willkommen zu meinem
letzten video aus der subway woche ich
bin schon fast ein bisschen traurig dass
sie vorbei ist aber ihr könnt mir einmal
schreiben wie sie euch bis jetzt
gefallen hat und wie euch mein highlight
der woche gefällt nämlich die raspberry
cheesecake cookies von subway und ich
glaube neben all den cookie anfragen ist
das die größte anfragen die ich bekommen
habe von euch ihr wolltet alle die
investoren cookies und das ist so ein
relativ langer weg gewesen bis zu diesem
rezept weil wir waren uns nicht einig
sei die schokolade drin oder nicht nein
ich sage jetzt eine cheesecake stückchen
drin haben sie durchaus der meinung der
sind weist schoko drops drin
umhüllt von schokolade und es ging sogar
soweit dass wir gestern zwei minuten vor
feierabend um 22 58 noch zu subway
gefahren sind um uns zu vergewissern
näheres seht ihr dann im blog oder habt
ihr vielleicht schon gesehen ich
verlinke euch den block noch mal damit
ihr das ganze auch nach erfolgen können
jetzt wirklich einfach mal sagen wir
fangen an mit dem genial zum rezept er
war denn ich habe herumexperimentiert
und ich habe es wieder herausgefunden
so gehen die subway cookies raspberry
cheesecake dafür habe ich jetzt hier
butter in einer rührschüssel das ganze
muss gleich nur kurz verrührt werden die
butter ist zimmer waren super super
wichtig da gebe ich jetzt braunem zucker
mit dazu und das ganze ruhig jetzt mit
der maschine nur ein bis eineinhalb
minuten und ihr könnt könnt jetzt auch
euer handrührgerät verwenden denn gleich
in die sowieso mit dem schneebesen bzw
mit dem teig schaber weiter
[Musik]
als nächstes vanille extrakt und das ei
dazugeben kurz unterrühren
und dann kommen auch schon die trockenen
zutaten dafür benötigen wir mehl und
backpulver und das liebe ich gerne vorab
damit einfach keine klümpchen mehr im
teig sind und das ganze dann auch nur
kurz unter rennen dann erhaltet ihr
einen sehr festen teig und je nachdem
wie kleines ei ist ich nehme jetzt das
größte es könnte auch presse entnehmen
bräuchte tier noch ein zwei stücke ich
das schreibe ich euch aber ganz genau
nochmal unten in die video beschreibung
da stehen generell alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben und jetzt fehlt ja nur
noch die cheesecake masse und natürlich
die himbeer und da ich keine frischen
hinnehmen möchte weil sie einfach zu
feucht sind und später dann nicht mehr
schön im endergebnis aussehen aber auch
den cookies ein bisschen verunstalten
nämlich getrocknete hier mehren und die
könnt ihr einfach so in den teig geben
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig an sich erst mal
fertig und jetzt fehlen natürlich die
spezifik anteil also die cheesecake
masse und ich habe gesehen also ich bin
natürlich auch auf den trails und so
weiter unterwegs gewesen weil ich mir
einfach den kopf darüber zerbrochen habe
aber ich glaube auch keines opel cookies
da hatte ist da jetzt echt heiße
schokolade drin oder sieht es nur aus
die weiße schokolade und es ist in
wahrheit einfach in so einem schieß
cache drop weil das wird ja auch in der
firma hergestellt und so weiter und dann
ist mir aufgefallen dass auf sämtlichen
blogs immer weiße schokolade benutzt
wird und ich finde das ist nicht richtig
sie damit ob cookies zu nennen weil es
ist einfach keine weiße schokolade drin
vielleicht arbeitet er jemand von euch
das abholen kann es im kurs bestätigen
und daher genau genau dann kann man sie
die haben so sagen einfach respekt
cookies netscape aber wer originalgetreu
zumindest geschmacklich das ganze nach
machen möchten habe ich hier folgendes
überlegen was hat auch sehr gut geklappt
in einem experiment ich nehme jetzt
einfach doppel ram frischkäse bitte hier
auch nicht die fettarme variante nehmen
gebe da zucker dazu vanilla extrakt und
speisestärke und dann wirklich nur ganz
kurz unteren das ist so wichtig dass sie
nicht zu lange rührt damit die masse
nicht so flüssig wird ihn anschließend
fülle ich sie mir in mein spritzbeutel
mit filtern und dann zeige ich euch
gleich wie wir die in die cookies
reinbekommen
[Musik]
so leute jetzt kommt der spannende teil
ich habe jetzt jemanden backblech da
habe ich ein backpapier draufgelegt und
eben jetzt den ice portionierer damit
könnt ihr sicher stellen dass alle
cookies gleich groß sind alle gleich
lang brauchen bis sie gebacken sind und
da gebe ich euch gleich auch noch
wertvolle tipps was ihr beim backen
beachten müsst jetzt nehme ich mir
einfach vom teig eine ja ein eis
portionierer voll und ganz ganz wichtig
bitte lasst abstand auf dem backblech
damit sie damit ihr nicht einen riesen
cookie am ende bekommt ich mache auch
immer nur sechs auf einmal ist alles
andere als zu riskant schill mit viel
abstand
[Musik]
und als nächstes nehmen wir uns jetzt
den vorbereiteten spritzbeutel mit der
cheesecake füllung und das ist jetzt so
praktisch mit der fülle der teig ist
schon relativ fest und deswegen stehe
ich da einfach ganz leicht rein und
drückt also ein bisschen von der masse
raus ich zeige es euch jetzt am besten
mal
[Musik]
so jetzt kommen die cubis in den
backofen ganz ganz wichtig hat den
backofen immer vor und zwar in dem fall
auf 180 grad ober und unterhitze und
dann ins untere einschub drittel und
zwar für circa zehn maximal 13 minuten
jeder backofen backt anders manche sind
einfach heißer als angegeben
da müssen wir schon nach zehn minuten
raus andere nach 11 12 oder maximal 13
minuten bitte achtet darauf dass die
cookies nicht zu dunkel werden sie
sollen noch sehr hell bleiben und
maximal außenrum in ganz dünnen braunen
rand haben und dann wenn sie perfekt und
wir sehen uns gleich wieder
so freunde die erste ladung ist fertig
wenn mir jetzt ganz genau elf minuten
gedauert aber trotzdem im auge trauben
ja die sind wirklich perfekt sich immer
ganz vorsichtig mit meiner toilette an
die dürfen auch nicht dunkler werden das
ist das maximum so sind so richtig schön
shui natürlich mache ich gleich auch
noch ein keks für euch auf aber ich
zeige euch hier erst mal mein zweites
blech da habe ich auch wieder sechs
stück drauf das rezept ist perfekt für
zwölf cookies und natürlich dürft ihr da
auch weiße schokolade mit rené sind
jetzt hier sehen wir das nicht machen
würden oder könnt ihr auch mal
dann sind aber keineswegs cookies mehr
cookies und die gibt es ja so noch nicht
aber kurz damit es euch gezeigt habe ich
habe hier meine besten weißem schoko
drops hier verlinkt ich euch natürlich
in der infobox und stecke ich einfach
jetzt hier ein paar in den teig ihr
müsst auch den teig nicht in japan
drücken das passiert alles wie von
alleine im backofen ist praktisch die
ladung auch noch und dann haben sie
machen den test noch ganz kurz abkühlen
lassen so und jetzt probieren wir mal
zusammen
weder der hamburger fabriziert
fabrizieren habe ich eine leckere
cookies wollen wir die zusammenarbeit
teilen nun heftig eine hälfte geht also
müssen sie aufgehen nicht brechen dann
wenn ihr zu trocken genau so muss es
sein
ja ich bitte darum ich bitte darum
gestern nach der auch ein original
subway cookie probiert
[Musik]
die saison gut heute ein bisschen
markieren ja genau nur die sagt kleines
land vom user sofort leute richtig sei
es richtig meisten wohl richtig
begeistert ein lob stimmt aber das steht
überhaupt ich hoffe ich ganz toll
ich finds richtig gut ja noch nicht
richtig toll macht unbedingt nach was
solche zusage ist genial ist einfach ein
geniales rezept ich schreibe euch wie
immer alles hier unten in die video
beschreibung ansonsten haben soll soll
was sollen die was soll die key militärs
machen natürlich ein bäumchen nach oben
da lassen wir euch das rezept und ich
würde sagen wir packen das jetzt einen
wollte man jetzt noch die familie
besuchen
wir packen den rest jetzt ein und
dadurch ist man diesen sokolenko ja und
dann tue so als wären wir jetzt einfach
mal gucken ob dies mehr als okay wir
dürfen jetzt wir nehmen wir mal auf
instagram mit beschreiben euch unsere
instagram kanäle hier einfach in die
video beschreibung mit dazu und dann
sehen wir uns beim nächsten rezept und
falls ihr eine andere reihe möchte von
irgendeinem fast food laden dann
schreibt gerne auch in die kommentare
und wir wollen uns schauen wir mal was
wird was wird okay ich bin sicher sagen
genauso wie sein genau so muss es sein
ok bis zum nächsten mal auf das kitzeln
[Musik]